tonight the New York Post just in former
president Donald Trump has told allies
he could announce the 2024 presidential
run tonight at a rally for a higher
Republican Senate candidate J.D Vance
the post has learned let's bring in
Jason Miller a former senior advisor to
president Trump
um Jason welcome to the program great to
have you on a huge anticipation that
Donald Trump may even announce as early
as tonight he's going to run again my
guess is he will run again pretty much
whatever happens in the midterm short of
every candidate he's promoted losing
which I think is unlikely let me ask you
a question though you work closely with
the man is it a good thing for America
if Donald Trump runs again with a you
know a 50 50 chance perhaps of winning
the White House again
well I'm obviously a trump partisan I
worked for him in both 2016 and 2020 and
so I very much want to see Trump come
back in 2024. I think what we've seen in
the U.S with the economy going downhill
with the inflation all the things that
everybody realizes and why we're going
to have this tidal wave of an election
tomorrow that's all part of the reason
why I want to see President Trump come
back but I think more importantly peers
on the global stage when you have a weak
American democracy a weak leadership in
the White House it reverberates all the
way across the world and you see the
rise of Russia the rise of China and all
the bad guys don't have anyone to push
back on them that's a very interesting
moment this week I thought when the the
rising Republican star is the the
Florida governor Ron DeSantis expected
to to get easily re-elected in the
midterms and Trump suddenly who's been
you know sort of not saying anything
publicly but knifing him privately
suddenly he did it publicly let's take a
look
let's say there it is Trump at 71 Rhonda
sanctimonious at 10 percent
now I'm going to hand it to Trump he is
a master of giving people very damaging
uh mocking nicknames but it also opened
up this very real possibility now that
he does get challenged by DeSantis who
is pretty near half his age uh done a
very good job in Florida he's very
popular there and he's seen as the sort
of Trump without all the baggage of
Maddies what do you make of DeSantis and
was it helpful for Trump to do this
right before an important election for
the Republicans
yeah great question so in a conventional
lens if you look through this it would
make no sense to go after Ron DeSantis
now right before an election DeSantis is
going to win in a landslide in Florida
help carry a number of the Republicans
across the finish line but very clearly
president Trump does not look at things
through a traditional political lens if
he had he probably wouldn't have won in
2016 or come as close as he would have
had in 2020. I think president Trump
clearly is thinking about DeSantis knows
that DeSantis is likely to challenge him
even in a Republican primary if Trump
says that he's running and so he decided
that heading into Tuesday he's going to
throw a little love tap as they'd say
here in New York at Governor DeSantis so
caught a lot of people off guard they're
upset by it but clearly president
Trump's looking ahead to 2024. President
Biden I mean I would imagine if you're
the Republicans there was you're praying
for uh on running again because Biden
looks half Gaga and he's approaching 80
years old
yeah and there's a there's a
counter-intuitive Point here in that
Trump announcing early could also Force
Joe Biden to announce early keep in mind
Biden's only real value proposition is
that he defeated president Trump in
2020. a lot of Democrats do not want Joe
Biden running in 2024 they want him to
step aside let in someone else like a
Gavin Newsom or Gretchen Whitmer or one
of the other Governors around the
country so if Trump announces early then
you get Biden early it might lock him in
that could actually be a Big Boon for
president Trump uh whereas if president
Trump were to delay maybe the Democrat
leadership can get to him and convince
Biden you know what it's are we looking
are we looking just quick answer very
are we looking for a slam dunk Red Wave
where they'd say the house and the
Senate
yeah big huge Red Wave you've seen about
a 30 35 Point shift with Independence
just over the last month the bottom has
completely fallen out for Democrats even
CNN is saying that races such as the
Senate contest in New Hampshire are up
for grabs I think Republicans come out
of this with 53 maybe 54 Senate seats
big majority in the house this is going
to be not just
lend any attempt any any chance of Biden
doing anything more substantial while
he's president and we'll open up that
although that's a good thing yeah
that's a good shooter yeah
it's just more his demeanor which is so
embarrassing I think for America uh
Jason before letting you go you're
involved with this website uh getter
Elon Musk has taken over Twitter
obviously so technically your rival what
do you make of of Elon Musk very quickly
if you don't mind
yeah obviously Elon Musk is a rival now
that he's the head of Twitter uh but you
have to support what he's trying to do
try to bring some normalcy uh to Twitter
an organization that's gone very far to
the left end a lot of political
discrimination of course the election
2020 and the hunter Biden laptop I have
to support him there Pierce I don't
think the culture at Twitter can be
changed that's the only reason why
that's going to be others Jackson go
leave that uh thank you very much I
agree with you it's going to be very
difficult if anyone can do it it'll be a
genius like musk uh Jason thank you very
much
thank you